This is from Destiny's attorneys. This
is filed in connection with her motion
for preliminary injunction. Plaintiff
moves to file under seal. Your client
also threatened physical harm to other
individuals that have spoken out against
him and in support of the plaintiff. For
Jtock and Queen, I if I could, I'd show
up to their house and do it. I do want
someone to J though or Lav or Mr. Girl
or Queen. All those people can go die.
Damn, that don't sound so cute on paper.
No, it doesn't. And it's I don't know
how. So, this gets replied to. I wonder
if there's any comment on this at all.
You wouldn't do you are a pathetic
loser.
Destiny's kind of arguing to these
people. Hey, I shouldn't have to I these
shouldn't be like filed right away
without, you know, the motion to seal
being finished. There's like there's
some procedural thing here, but there's
like a couple different things to talk
about. So here, what do we got? Document
72. This is the initial filing. Okay, so
this is Oh, hold on. What is this
called? This is explicitly response and
opposition to motion. Response in
opposition to plaintiff's motion for
leave to file declarations under seal
filed by Steven Banell's attorneys.
Replies due by May 16th. Okay. All
right. You guys keep saying things to
like troll Kelly. I do not like it. I do
not like it. I do not like it. Please
stop. Please stop. Okay. So, this is
from Destiny's attorneys. This is filed
in connection with her motion for
preliminary injunction. Plaintiff moves
to file under seal. Huh? You can't see
anything? Uh, no. I didn't see any
trolling. But also, sorry. I'm just
trying to fix there's like I was just
trying to fix the OBS thing. Sorry. I
don't know if this is going to work, but
I I've got it open. I just skipped the
version and hopefully it works. I'm not
sure. Someone sends a dono. Then we'll
be able to check. Soap Society says,
"Have they ruled out Aaylor's Danlas?"
Kelly, they've given me a So, they do a
capillaroscopy of your fingernails to
check for vascular instability with a
damos, which they have done. Although
that's not Are you super flexible,
Kelly? I'm not. So, it's not one one of
the ones I'm worried about, but there is
a vascular version of it was down. Okay.
Imagine where your vascular system is
stretchy. Doesn't sound good, does it?
Uh, no. Doesn't sound good. Okay. Going
again. In connection with her motion for
preliminary injunction. Plaintiff moves
to file under seal three anonymous
declarations. Plaintiff's motion should
be denied for three reasons. Plaintiff
failed to meet and confer prior to
filing her motion. So, if we remember,
that was something that uh the judge
asked them to do was to stop filing
motions. Although, I don't know if that
necessarily requires the uh like if this
required the judge to okay something,
then maybe it'll it'll depend on how the
judge rules this, right? So, this is all
going to come down to when they filed
these
fear. Okay, $10. Hope you feel better.
Sophia donated to say, "Hope you feel
better." Yeah, I got it cuz it worked.
Thank you. So this is all to do with um
Destiny or sorry Pixie's team filing
these affidavit as redacted filings.
Okay. So under penalty of perjury of
blank blank this is the person's full
name. Okay. So the issue here is
Destiny's team says we need the
identities of these people. We want the
identities of these people and we think
unredacted copies should be filed um in
the meantime or these should be stricken
from the record. So basically the
argument will basically be is Destiny
trying to push them to file unredacted
copies to get these people to recant or
are they, you know, filing normal
procedures under like normally under
court procedures? And I think I think
Pixie's legal team has an like an
argument for not wanting to file these
unredacted or give these to the the
defendant unredacted because basically
Destiny's team has twice now taken
private deliberations in in uh like
conference and made them public. SNC
will say, "Well, you didn't talk to us
about this." And they want the the
identities of the people who have filed
these, right? So, it's some argument
between is this an intimidation tactic?
Yes. Or is this um like what is this?
Destiny knows who these people are 100%
because obviously beginning in late May
2024, our conversations progressively
became more personal. We began
exchanging private like all of these
have like timelines for when they when
they started talking to him, stopped
talking to him, exactly what their their
correspondence was for all these things,
right? So, there's no reason Destiny
wouldn't know who these people are. He
would have records of who these people
are. Literally, that's his testimony is
I've saved all of these records. I have
records of all these people. Can we zoom
in a bit more, please? Uh, sure. Thank
you. Sure. Sure. So, yeah. So,
basically, it's these ones that they
want um unredacted copies of these. I
believe they argue for unredacted copies
of these filed, but I didn't do a deep
read through of these things. So, we'll
we'll see exactly what they say. So the
reasoning for this is u plaintiff uh
plaintiff Pixie Pixie's legal team
failed to meet and confer prior to
filing her motion. Plaintiff refuses to
identify the names of the declarance to
defendant Benell's council. And three,
the federal rule and statute upon which
plaintiff relies are not applicable
here. Um okay. I think what Pixie's team
should do is they should talk about how
Destiny was reaching out to a bunch of
people about Abby before she'd even
before it was even filed regardless of
how it was filed, redacted or not.
Right. That's a little concerning I
would say. But anyway, at 7:59 p.m. EDT
on Friday, May 2nd, 2025, Plaintiff's
Council emailed the undersigned stating,
"Pursuant to local rule 7.1, we are
meeting and conferring on the following
motions. Motion to file under seal
certain documents and it and its
proposed order. Motion for leave to
exceed page limit on reply memorandum.
The documents to be filed under seal are
certain statements by witnesses which
purpose is to keep uh who which whose
purpose? Which purpose? I whose purpose,
right? I don't know how you'd say this
in in plural. Which purpose is to keep
their names out of the public? You and
your client will know their identities.
I apologize for not reaching out before
it's been an intense week. Okay, so
they're basically saying, "Hey, we're
we're filing these things." Um, the way
I see this is they're saying, "Okay, we
don't know exactly how this is going to
work. We're filing it redacted because
we don't want the identities to be
exposed publicly, and now we're meeting
in conference to discuss the exact way
we're going to pursue this." Okay. Uh,
supplementary Breler declaration a
emphasis added at 11:40 p.m. on May 2nd.
Plaintiff filed her motion for leave to
file declarations under seal ECF number
48. At 12:05 a.m. EDT on Saturday, May
3rd, after the deadline to file her
reply papers, plaintiff filed the
declarations in redacted form. ECF 424
42 or 492 494 495. At 10 a.m. PDT on May
3rd. 10 a.m. PDT on May 3rd. Banell's
council requested unredacted copies of
plaintiff's filings. Supple
supplementary Breler declaration
declaration exhibit B. Despite so we'll
go through these as well. Despite
repeated requests, plaintiff refused to
reveal to Benell the names of her
defendants or declarants. Sorry. The
local rule requires a filer filing a
redacted exhibit to contemporaneously
serve a version of the exhibit upon all
council that is either unredacted or
that contains only the the those
redactions authorized in connection with
producing a document to another party in
discovery.
Uh so this has not been discovered yet.
This has not been like determined yet.
So I think what they're arguing is
basically the judge hadn't agreed to
file things under seal and you're filing
as if they'd agreed to file under seal.
I think that's what he's basically
arguing here to date. This is local
rules
5.4F1A. To date, plaintiff has not
complied. Supplementary declaration
paragraph 5. Instead, plaintiff argues
that because she elected to file
redacted declarations under rule local
rule 5.3b1, she is somehow excused from
the requirement of subse subsection F of
the local rule and contends that Banell
has no right to receive the unredacted
documents at this time. I think I don't
know if I don't know if that's the
argument. We'll see. So, plaintiff
provides no support for this contention.
At minimum, Banell should be permitted
to know the identities of the purported
witnesses who are providing testimony
against him. Again, he knows the
identities. He's literally checked in on
Abby with all of his friends, right?
Like, he's literally gone directly to
his friends to check in on these things.
Florida Sunshine Law wouldn't have
jurisdiction here. This is federal
court. Oh, interesting. Well, I think I
think a lot of people think the local
rules should apply here. I actually
think Pixie's team is support is citing
the local rules as well. So, that's
interesting. Further plaintiffs reliance
on rule rule 26 C1 of the federal rules
of civil procedure and 15 USC6851 is
entirely misplaced and those authorities
have no bearing on her motion to file
under seal. Rule 26 pertains to seeking
a protective order in connection with
discovery. Federal rules of civil
procedure 26 C1. The code the code
section provides that the court may
grant injunctive relief maintaining the
confidentiality of a plaintiff under a
pseudonym 15 USC 6851 B3 uh B3B. Neither
is applicable here. For the foregoing
reasons, Banell request that the court
deny plaintiff's motion to file under
seal and order the plaintiff to file
unredacted versions of declarations or
strike them from the record. I think
there's obviously another thing here
where they could say, "Hey, we wanted to
file these things because we didn't know
if they need to be filed in time for the
motion." Like basically, we were having
issues filing. We we were trying to file
last second and we wanted these filed
because we weren't sure. And we figured
the safest way to do that because we're
filing under seal is to file the
redacted copies and then let you make
your decision.
local rules are the federal district
local rules. Oh, I see. Okay. So, that's
their their argument is basically like
you don't have any ability to do this
unless the judge makes a ruling. So, I
think probably it seems like this is
again them saying it seems like Pixie's
team hadn't filed the motion to or
hadn't made the motion to file under
seal and then they had all of these
statements and they filed it all at the
last second as the as the deadline was
approaching, right? They didn't want to
miss the deadline. Okay. And this is one
of the witness statements. So, I want to
go now to um Brett Ller provided this in
relation. So, this is his declaration.
Um funny enough, Destiny argued he's
like, "Wait, can lawyers just do this?
They can just file affidavit." And then
uh his lawyer did one literally within a
week. Good times. Yeah, obviously they
can, bro. What's that? What's that,
Kelly? Oh, zoom in. I got it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I got it. I didn't hear you,
but I did it anyway. I Andrew B. Breler
declare pursuant to 28 USC 1746 as
follows. I am an attorney admitted to a
practice pro. Oh, eports Batman, if you
want to come on, you can come on so we
can review this stuff if you're
interested. Um, hop in the waiting room
of that other Discord if you want to hop
on. Up to you, though. Uh, I am an
attorney. There he is. Oh, cool. What's
up? So, uh, I'm going to link you the,
uh, local rules and they specifically
outline how to file, uh, disposal of
materials under, uh, sealed. Well, this
specific rule is 5.4. for filings under
seal disposal of sealed materials. Yeah,
the way I see it is they probably or the
way I read that the way I read it was um
that probably they need to file a motion
to seal and talk to the judge and then
the judge could make a determination,
right? Yeah. Ideally, that's how you
want to do it. And and under federal
rules, like the general federal rules,
not the specific local rules, that's
generally how you would follow it under
rule 26, which is kind of their
contention. But if as I understand it
with regards to the local rules, there
is an allowance for this. Um there there
is an allowance for this. There is a
limited allowance for this. I'll Okay,
let me look through the rules real quick
and I'll find you the specific section.
Uh but Caiba already linked to it was
pretty on top of things. So let me go
ahead and read through the local rules
real quick. Oh, sure. I'm going to read
Breler's declaration here. Uh I, Andrew
B. Threatler declare pursuant to 28 USC
1746 as follows. I think this is the you
don't have to um I think it's under
penalty of perjury, right? It's probably
that one again. I am an at maybe not. I
actually literally don't know. Hold on.
I assume that's what it is. But unsworn
declarations under penalty. It is. Thank
god. Okay. I am an attorney admitted to
practice Brohawk Viche in the above
captioned action. I am a partner at the
law firm Burke Bretler LLP in West
Hollywood, California along with our
local council at Bills and uh Sberg Bay
and Axelrod LLP. We we represent
defendant Steven Kanel II. I have
personal knowledge of the matters
contained herein and if called to
testify called upon to testify could
offer competent testimony there too. I
submit this supplemental declaration
declaration in connection with Benell's
opposition to plaintiff's motion to file
under seal ECF number 48. Three
anonymous declarations ECF numbers 492
494 495 plaintiff filed in support for
her motion for preliminary injunction
ECF number 21. Uh, attached here to as
exhibit A is a true and correct copy of
emails I received from plaintiffs
council on May 2nd, 2025. Attached here
to as exhibit B is a true and correct
copy of my email exchange with
plaintiffs council from May 3rd to May
5th, 2025. Despite my repeated requests,
today plaintiff's council could have
council have refused to identify the
declarance whose declarations were filed
in redacted form. I declare under
penalty of perjury that the foregoing is
shrink executed on May 9th, 2025. So
he's saying that um maybe I I think the
other argument they have here esports
Batman and as you read this you can um
you can see I think they are arguing
that they should be provided in any case
with the identities of these people
directly right like the the defense
should be provided with the identities
of these people generally speaking yes
but uh this is I put it in chat which is
that if prior to the issuance of a
ruling on the motion to file under seal
the moving party elects or is required
to publicly file a pleading motion
memoran random or other document that
attaches or reveals the content of the
proposed sealed material, then the
moving party must redact from the public
filings all content that is subject to
the motion to file under seal. Yeah,
that would that would do it. And then if
the court grants the motion to file
under seal, then the moving party shall
file any pleading motion, memorandum or
other document that has been authorized
to uh be filed under seal via CM ECF
using events specifically earmarked for
sealed civil filings. But if a redacted
filing previously has been made or is
accompanied the sealed filing then the
material is being filed under seal shall
be uh filed as attached to notice of
sealed filing which is which shall be uh
filed via
CM/ecf. The moving party must complete
any required service of the sealed
filing or notice of sealed filing uh
conventionally indicating the
corresponding docket number of the
sealed file filing or notice of sealed
filing. though that's my understanding
is they did provide notice and if I'm
reading the rule correctly which I may
or may not I you know I'm not a Florida
attorney who practices in the federal
courts of Miami. It allows you to kind
of preemptively file it if you have to
and then the court will make a decision
and then you can either refile it or you
can without the seal or you can that
makes total sense to me where they had a
deadline for their reply to the motion
to oppose the motion to whatever, right?
They were filing under a deadline. They
had to file and they said, "Okay, we
need to because a part of our filing is
a motion to seal. We're filing the
redacted pieces and then we can talk to
the judge about the motion to seal. Yep.
Okay. And then the the chief um the
chief rebuttal from Breler here, the
first one, I assume these are in order
of strength, is plaintiff failed to meet
and confer prior to filing her motion.
Now, I think Pixie's team should say,
"Okay, first you released our private um
pre-trial negotiations over settlement.
You released those in order to win a PR
battle. And then after we discussed um
basically, hey, Pixie didn't want you
after we discussed this preliminary
injunction stuff, basically Pixie said,
okay, I'll take down my Substack post if
you'll take down your videos, like
exposing my DMs, right? And then Destiny
leaked that publicly on his stream.
Pixie didn't leak that. Destiny leaked
that publicly on his stream. I think
they have a strong argument for our
conferences are actually just being used
to wage PR war and we don't trust this
party at all. In fact, we we basically
don't even trust them to have these
names. No. Yeah. Not to mention that the
very facet of the conferences being
pre-trial and being uh more or less
secretive is being completely blown out
of the water by you know one of the
parties completely leaking everything in
real time or just thereafter their
occurrence. So yeah I I can understand
the argument from Pixie side. But what
is his argument going to be like? Your
honor, I goon too hard and I spoke to
too many women. Yeah. To be clear, Pixie
is the moving party for this preliminary
who these people are and the moving
party for filing these as well.
Obviously, he knows who these people
are, but what he wants is their legal
identity so he can go around and dox
them and like intimidate and humiliate
them because why the else would he need
a legal information? I mean, presumably
as far as like Abby is concerned, he has
that. So then he knows that. So what is
he by giving him unsealed versions of
this? What is he receiving that he
doesn't already have? There's there's an
argument to be made there. It might be
one of the other two anonymous people
that has probably it. That's I want to
read this and I want to see how
reasonable it is that you wouldn't know
given the timeline who this person is.
So this this is one of the people. Um I
think this is Hold on. Is this this is
this should be witness a I believe. I'm
over 18 years of age. Blah blah blah
blah. Beginning on May 25th, 2024, I
began exchanging messages with Destiny
on Instagram and subsequently on
Discord, where I engaged with him as a
fan. Shortly thereafter, beginning in
late May 2024, our conversation
progressed and became more personal,
began exchanging private content with
one another graphic content of himself
alone, as well as graphics content
depicting himself and other individuals
engaging in facts. Destiny shared some
of these videos with me directly via
Discord messages, but the majority of
them were shared through a Google Drive
link, which he sent me via Discord for
the first time on or about early June
2024. The graphics content that he
shared with me was mostly digital
videos, although there were some digital
photographs as well. I ceased contact
with Destiny on or about November 5th,
2024. Subsequently became aware of the
allegations that there had been online
leaks of Destiny engaging in acts with
individuals. On or about January 21st, I
became aware of Jane Do's post. this
one. Maybe he It's possible he doesn't
know who this is. That he started a
relationship with somebody on Discord in
May 2024 and that it progressed quickly.
Maybe that is not enough for him. Okay.
Although I had access to messages
between myself and Destiny at that point
on January 21st. Okay. So this basically
this is what I was looking for is he
should have access within his logs that
he saved. So they say although I had
access to messages between myself and
Destiny at that point January 21st.
Sometime afterward, I discovered that
Destiny had deleted messages between me
and him on Discord and subsequently
discovered that I no longer had access
to the Google Drive containing the
graphics content which appeared to be
deleted. So again, he should have logs
of this anyway, right? Yep. Yeah. Okay.
Yep. All right. I'm going to hop out,
but I if you check your DMs, I linked
you to the portion of the local rules
that I read earlier in case you want to
go over them later on or if you wanted
to read up on them further. Okay, neat.
All right, take it easy. Talk to you
later. See you. Bye. Okay, so this is uh
this is the other this would be witness
B I think. Yeah, this should be witness
B. So on or about April 20, 2022, I
reached out to defendant Steven K.
Benell Destiny via Twitter. Shortly
thereafter, we arranged to get together
in blank where we began a relationship.
Thereafter, Destiny and I remained in
contact and I also became friendly with
his wife at the time, Molina Garansson.
At some point, Destiny asked me if I was
comfortable with him sharing videos/p
pictures of content involving himself as
well as his himself and his wife. I told
him that I did consent to his sharing
these videos with me. Uh thereafter, we
began sharing pictures and videos of the
nature with one another. Most of the
other most of the videos that Destiny
sent were of him alone. However, at
least one of these videos included
himself and his wife. On or about mid to
late April 2023, Destiny invited me to
blank where he and was staying briefly.
Well, so again, where were you in April
2023 and who did you invite to there?
It's like you you literally know who
this is, right? Your honor, I goed too
hard in April of 2023. I don't know who
that was. Uh Destiny invited me to blank
where he was staying briefly. While at
blank, Destiny recorded himself and I
engaging in acts. The recordings were
made with my consent and I authorized
Destiny to share these record the
recordings with his wife exclusively. I
did not authorize Destiny to share these
recordings with anyone else or to
otherwise make them public. Thereafter,
I continued to communicate with Destiny
online. In late November 2024, I was
harassed by multiple individuals while
on Discord who informed me that a video
involving Destiny and myself had leaked
online. After confirming this that this
was was the case, I confronted Destiny
who told me that he was sorry that any
videos involving myself had leaked
because of him. Destiny also told me
that he had only shared the this content
with a single individual who went by the
screen name Rose. Following the
conversation, I received messages from
multiple women on Discord and Twitter
who had been in contact with Destiny and
who told me that Destiny had shared with
them content depicting myself as well as
others. Excuse me. Sometime after the
November 29th, 2024 leaks, I discovered
that Destiny deleted messages between
himself and I related to the forgoing.
So, he absolutely knows who this is. And
I can't imagine he doesn't know who the
other one is. Maybe he doesn't know who
the other one is. As Destiny said before
that he keeps like an Excel document of
his partners or am I making that up?
You're not making that up. That is
accurate. He has said that. Yes. Is it
appropriate to include testimony at
other videos Destiny sent that were not
related to directly to Pixie? Uh, so
Destiny will say no. But there is
something to say like hey this pattern
this this exact pattern of behavior does
relate like quite closely and and could
be used like basically because the
timelines match up so closely. It seems
like it's indication like if you had a
pattern of somebody robbing banks in the
exact time frame that you're accusing
them of robbing a bank. I do believe
that is relevant information. Now it
will be relevant like contextual
information but is it proof? I don't
know. Right. So it's like is it will
depend on whether or not it p it
pertains directly to the exact crime
being alleged. I think right and that
there could be a pattern of behavior
there around that crime. I just
generally proving that they're like a
person or something. I think that can be
taken away but I do believe there are
arguments there's there's an exact name
for it. Major Windy always sends it to
me whenever I there's a there's a name
for this kind of evidence and it there
is a high bar to having it included.
Like it needs to be directly related. It
needs to be like kind of directly
related to one of the charges and show
like there is some pattern going on
there. These will be like supporting
pieces of evidence to subpoena Google
and Discord and to try to get like yeah
copies of his messages and stuff. We can
only hope. Anyway, so that was all to
say that's u that's basically he's
saying I don't know who these people
are. Seems a little absurd to me. I
think he should probably have a list. I
would imagine you'd have a list of the
people you shared those documents to
that you should be able to go check some
permissions and stuff. But yeah, we know
it's 4 to playing the uh ye old the
early onset Alzheimer's card. I don't
know who these people are. No clue. The
suggesting to the court that he doesn't
know who these people are based off of
the information they gave in these
statements help his case makes him sound
super degenerate. Um I don't believe it
should hurt his case. I don't think so.
It does make him sound insanely
degenerate, but yeah, I don't think it
necessarily hurts his case. Sure. Okay.
Lagono, I don't remember anything. So EP
Okay. Uh, so we went from this guy. Now
I think the other things attached here
are copies of the emails. And I think
I'm referenced here, which is super
cool. Love to get love to get a shout
out once in a while, you know. Always
cool to get a shout out. Can't they just
show Destiny joking about wanting your
docs and you and Que and shut that down
immediately? Uh, Nyrosocks, you would be
shocked. Okay, but but I will talk about
a couple things here because we need to
go through these emails real quick and
these emails are going to include some
interesting stuff. So this is uh this is
document A. This is exhibit A from here
or the copies of the emails. This is
going to be what they wanted to show to
show that he was asking for the
identities of the people. So sorry is
A2. Thank you. And then May 2nd. Good
afternoon Andrew. I hope you're doing
well. Pursuant to local rule 7.1A 3, we
are meeting and conferring. We're
meeting and conferring on the following
motions. Motion to file under seal
certain documents and it proposed order.
Motion for leave to exceed uh page limit
on reply memorandum. These documents to
be filed under seal are certain
statements by witnesses which purpose is
to keep their names out of the public.
You and your client will know their
identities. I apologize for not reaching
out before it's been an intense week.
Please let me know and thank you. So,
this is 7:59 p.m. Let me look back. I
just want to see here when did they file
these because they should have been on
what? May 3rd. May 2nd. May 3rd. So,
it's like these are even stretching into
May 3rd here. Okay. This email says May
2nd. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think basically
it's like slightly after May 2nd is when
Oh, maybe not. Okay. No, it's May 3rd.
All right. Sorry. I was just I was a
little confused. The deadline for them
replying, I believe, was May 3rd. Was it
May 2nd? Hold on. Hold on. Let me Let me
make sure I know here. Ah, whatever.
It's not It's not a big deal. Basically,
I think Andrew Brettler accused them of
not making the deadline because they
were filing late into the night. Seems
like they had issues with things. It's
midnight. It's fine. A uh Okay. Um, I
think basically it was that it wasn't
before midnight, but it it doesn't
really matter. I I would assume like,
hey, we literally it's like 12:03 when
these got filed. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry, but I think it's like it's 12:03
when they get filed, right? Did Destiny
ever actually get JTO's docs info? Well,
he thinks so. He says he published it
and he says it's correct. So, he
literally himself purported to have
published it. So, anyway, Mr. Bretler,
note that this is May 5th. I wonder why
we didn't get the emails in between
here. Mr. Mr. Breler, note that local
rules
54B1 provides inrelevant part if prior
to the issuance of a ruling on the
motion to file under seal. The moving
party elects or is required to publicly
file a pleading motion memorandum. This
is the one that esports Batman linked or
other document that attaches or reveals
the content of the proposed sealed
material. Then the moving party must
redact from the public filing all
content that is subject to the motion to
file under seal of a ruling on a motion
to the moving party elects or elects or
is required publicly. So I I'm guessing
this is meant to be like hey Alex or is
required publicly to file. I'm guessing
the moving party here if you're if
basically if there's a motion to file
under seal and then it says the moving
party. So I don't think that precludes
the idea that you would file a motion to
file under seal you would you'd say hey
we're filing under seal and then you
would be the moving party if you're
filing additional documents. Right? But
it's saying that even if the other side
wanted to file the documents themselves
if there is a pending motion to seal you
need to redact the things from that
motion to seal until there is a ruling.
Right. I think that is what this law is
saying. It's meant to cover both sides.
I believe esports Batman, you're
listening to me. You tell me if you
think otherwise. Okay. So, publicly file
a pleading motion memorandum or other
documents that attaches or reveals the
content of the proposed sealed uh
material. Then the moving party must
redact from public filing all content
that is subject to the motion to file
under seal. Plaintiff elected to attach
the declarations to the reply and file a
simultaneously simultaneous motion to
file under seal. Defendant has no right
to receive the unredacted documents at
this time. It would be highly negligent
if we were to provide to your client the
unredacted documents without the
protection of their identities by the
court in light of your client's public
statements over the weekend maligning
these declarants. Uh, these weren't over
the weekend, but sure. Uh, your client
has also threatened physical harm to Oh,
sorry. Over these declarants, maligning
these declarants. Oh, uh, this is Abby.
This is talking about Abby. So, he
literally was talking about Abby over
the weekend. Over the weekend. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay, cool. Individual. Um,
your client also threatened physical
harm to other individuals that have
spoken out against him and in support of
the plaintiff. For Jtock and Queen, I
them if I could, I'd show up to their
house and do it. I do want someone to
Jay-to though or Lav or Mr. Girl or
Queen. All those people can go die.
You wouldn't do you are a pathetic
loser. Yeah, he wouldn't. He's trying to
get somebody else. that just the mental
image of him trying to like punch
someone and just flailing around like a
[__] is just uh yeah it is funny.
Okay. It's sad. Sure. It is. It is. It
is. Damn. That don't sound so cute on
paper. No, it doesn't. And it's I don't
know how. So, this gets replied to. I
wonder if there's any comment on this at
all. Moreover, you have the full
unredacted
completely. I just going to like gloss
over that. Moreover, you have the full
unredacted substantive content of the
declarations. The only redacted portions
are those that would reveal the
identities of these declarants. There
can be no legitimate urgency for you or
your client to know the witness's legal
identities. That does not alter the
facts or your ability to defend your
client in these proceedings. Um, yeah, I
would say that is almost certainly true.
I do think there's a constitutional
right to face your accuser and these
people are like giving testimony in this
case. I don't know. Like obviously they
can't be these people can't, you know,
file without their identities, but I do
think it's fine to hide their
identities. I think what they're looking
for here is a confirmation from the
judge like, hey, if there's any leaking
of these things, like this is insane,
right? Like this guy's leaked a whole
bunch of information already. We need
you to like be on top of this, okay?
There can be no legit. Oh yeah, sure.
Sure. For these and other additional
reasons, we will not be providing the
underdacted documents unless they're
under seal. We consider our meet and
confer efforts to have been exhausted.
Uh, thank you to 69 Allen Ders 69 Allen
420 Dersowitz for the gifted sub. It was
over on Twitch. Thank you very much.
Okay, so then 2:47 p.m. When does this
come through? 153. So this is quoting
another thing but repeated requests. You
have
failed failed and or refused. Is this
all indirect? Maybe it is. You have
failed and or refused to provide us with
unredacted copies of declarations you
improperly filed with your reply papers
on Friday. Your continued failure and/or
refusal to provide the requested
documents violates local rule 5.4. You
do not immediately provide us with the
unredacted filings. We will so advise
the court and seek appropriate remedies
including but not limited to striking
the pleadings relying on the
unauthorized declarations and the
imposition of judicial sanctions against
you and your client. I mean you
literally it says in it's crazy that in
local rule 5.4 I believe it says
explicitly that failing to meet these
standards like the sanctions do not
include uh sanctions against the client
at all. Like this wouldn't harm Pixie's
case. This wouldn't harm Pixie in any
way. It would be basically only her
lawyers. If they if they were to say
this was against the rules, it only her
lawyers who would be in trouble, right?
And if the court doesn't grant your
emotion, their identities remain
anonymous. Yeah, that would be the
point. Yes. That like, hey, we want to
file like, okay, so here's the thing.
Pixie's team asked me to sign an
affidavit for them, right? That Desi had
doxed me and threatened to kill me and
all this. And I was like, oh yeah, sure.
As long as you can hide my identity.
this guy's clearly like calling for my
death on the internet. I don't want to
give my identity away in any way. Like
that, right? Um and they were like,
"Okay, well, we have to like file under
sea or whatever and blah blah blah blah
blah." They basically said like, "We can
protect it." And I was like, "Um, you
know what? I'm going to sit back a
little bit and I think you guys have
lots of time before trial and I'll I'll
chill." But that's exactly why cuz
they're trying to say like, "Hey, if if
the judge decides not to file this under
seal," which she spoke to her lawyers. I
had a meeting I was going to like I made
a statement to them, but then they were
like, "Hey, we need your identity. We
need like your name." And I'm like, I'm
not giving you that until I know you can
file it like privately. I've been
covering all of the stuff for this case.
I see all this getting filed publicly,
right? Not necessarily Destiny. I don't
trust this at all. This guy is scum.
This guy is actually scum. The Breler
guy. Oh, definitely. Yeah. I basically I
mean I would want basically confirmation
that, you know, this guy would be
destroying his reputation if my identity
got released, right? So I was like,
"Hey, I'll chill. I still might do it at
some point. Um, but I just like I
literally I'm like this guy's literally
calling for my death on the internet.
Why would I expose my identity? There's
no way I'm going to do that. That's
crazy, right? That's crazy. Uh, so we'll
see if this cuz basically they're trying
to say no, no, no. None of this should
be able to be filed under seal. No, no,
no. If if if the court overturns this
chance to file under seal, then their
identities should shouldn't be
anonymous, right? So anyway, uh to be
clear, because of your client's
statements related to Jane Doe and any
potential witnesses, we had to file
these under seal. Once the court rules
on the motion, we will proceed
accordingly. If the court grants the
motion, you will know their identities.
Thank you. Okay. Yeah. Honestly, I would
be fine. I would be fine if um if
there's like a a motion or sorry, a a
ruling that is filed under seal, I'd be
fine with that. Okay. Without the court
ruling on your motion to seal, you filed
redacted declarations. Please send me
the unredacted versions. in his belated
meet and confer email to me. Your
co-consel represented the documents to
be filed under seal are certain
statements by witnesses which which
whose purpose I think it's got to be
whose purpose is to keep their names out
of the public. You and your client will
know their identities. We do not. Please
provide that information. Thank you. So
he asked for it. Upon the ruling of the
court on our motion to file the
unredacted exhibits under seal docket
48, we will proceed to file the unacted
versions with the court at which point
you can access them. I would appreciate
a response to my email dated April 28th
regarding the Discord subpoena. So, it
seems like they just go back and forth.
It's they're just being asked, right?
So, she's like, "Yeah, um, literally the
court will give us a way to file under
seal and it will be accessible to you.
Do not do not ask me for this stuff.
Also, you've not responded to my about
the Discord subpoena from April 28th."
And he responds, "Please provide us with
the unre unreacted unreacted copies of
your filings immediately. Good evening.
We have a lot of trouble uploading some
of the exhibits. We tried for a couple
hours without success with some of them.
Uh, attached is the full blank blank
blank the full attached is the full set
of exhibits to plaintiff's Jane Doe
declaration that will be eventually be
uploaded. We apologize for the
inconvenience and we will try to solve
the issue over the weekend as soon as we
get some guidance from Pacer. Thank you.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So, how long
will it take for them to hear back from
the judge on the decision of whether
stuff will be under seal or not? Anyone
know that? I literally have no idea.
second here. Any legally people
listening? Uh, I don't know, but you
continue that conversation for a second,
Kelly. Okay. I was hoping someone might
Oh, he thought Batman said no idea. I
was just wondering what kind of a time
frame that usually is. Depends on how
busy the judge is. So, they did do they
mostly have to like stop until the judge
is like, "Yo, yeah, or no." Well, the
judge will have to Yeah, the judge will
have to make a ruling. I don't think
there's any more um motions that can be
filed. I think there's now going to be a
judge that will make a ruling. So, I
guess it will depend. I also don't know
because they filed these things under
their um under their preliminary
injunction. I don't know if they need to
refile these or amend their their um
their existing like complaints. I
actually have no idea how that's going
to work exactly. We'll see. Interesting.
We will see. We will see. Yeah. Um will
that stop like the back and forth until
like I don't know how long because like
the the dates they set were like
sometime next year, right, for all of
this to like finally go ahead or
whatever. I don't know how much they
have to like do like any ideas, guys. I
don't know what this shit's like. It's
funny because they always seem like the
time is running out of or whatever, but
I'm like this this it's going to be ages
in the future. Why is time running out?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, the end of the
year for discovery to be completed.
Okay. It's ages then. Why they always
seem like they're in a rush? Come Jesus.
that this is already granted by the
judge. Uh, no, I don't think so. So,
you're probably looking at a proposed
motion. Yeah, proposed order. This is
basically they're saying, "Hey, this is
what we think it should look like if you
want to sign it." They literally give
like a basically something for the judge
to sign. This is what we think it should
look like. You could sign this directly.
That is a proposed order. It's not
actually binding in any way. Okay. Uh, I
don't know how much there else there is
here. There's some other stuff here that
is kind of annoying, I guess. Um,
I can't talk about it on stream, but uh,
yeah, like I said, basically I feel like
the as soon as as soon as this motion to
seal is granted under this like proposed
thing, uh, I would definitely file like
an affidavit or something with uh, this
team as long as I know the the court's
going to actually protect my identity.
But I until then, until I I feel like
I'm confident that uh, it's not going to
be used maliciously against me, I'm
chilling. Chilling. You mean something
just happened or something you spoke
about before? Oh, I mean like it's some
older thing. Uh, hold on. I'll I'll
message you about it. Okay.